hey there guys I'm kidding in just
another quick one today I'm gonna be
giving you a little look at another new
triptych or smart drug called silt app
this is a nootropic stack meaning it's a
number of different ingredients all used
together hopefully synergistically and
it comes from natural stacks they sent
me this Potter of you so I thought I'd
give it a game and I was hoping that it
might provide me with a natural and
safer alternative to modafinil so caring
to a lot little detail regarding the
mechanisms of action for sill tech on my
blog talked about all the different
ingredients forskohlii and artichoke to
extract etc and how they're supposed to
work the general concept behind it
there's it's supposed to boot long term
potentiation this is the ability of your
neurons to communicate with each other
the strength of the synaptic connections
long-term potentiation means of that
connection gets stronger and this means
it's easier for them to communicate so
in theory it should help you build more
connections by the brain and cement the
ones you've got so ideally it should
help you with learning which it does by
increasing something called C amp which
is cyclic adenosine monophosphate which
comes from ATP the energy currency of
yourselves
like I said gets pretty complicated it
ultimately improves DNA transcription in
your neurons or does it it turns out
that there's a little bit of controversy
a recent reddit post that I was really
pointed out several studies that suggest
that the ingredients in still tech might
not be enough to stimulate the kind of
effect that that you're hoping to get
this is often a problem with many
miracle supplements much as those very
droll recently resveratrol is a a
substance found in red wine and supposed
to boost mitochondrial function as well
as being a very effective antioxidant it
was found to have amazing effects when
used on mice and everyone assumed it was
great when around spending lots of money
on
then Studies on humans found that the
amount we'd have to consume
if your human size is just too great we
really have any effect
so there's concern that the amount of
active components in the four scallion
and the artichoke extract isn't enough
to have the same effect on humans as
it's been shown to have in mice there's
also another concern that it can
increase a turtle : Cohen s phrase
something like that which has made some
people feel tired but they include
aissatou l-carnitine to try and combat
that prevent being tied my that's
because it's at our current net release
I really can't say that again you go
through my blog this stuff that you
break the juices when C amp is increased
can make some people feel tired which to
me says that actually one way or another
it is increasing
CM cyclic adenosine monophosphate and
that it could increase newer neural
connections so although there's no
studies to support it
the these small doses working in humans
there's also no things to say it doesn't
and really just gonna have to take it
from what people say and make up your
own decisions not me maybe try it
yourself personally what did I find
that's that's really what this review is
about except you can get more in depth
with the mechanisms of action then read
the blog post but for me personally well
first of all what's the space that we're
supposed to do is improve memory as as
mentioned but also your some people say
the groups that desire to learn possibly
13 piece of dopamine in this also have a
precursor to dopamine it l-phenylalanine
I don't know why everything has to be so
difficult to say but if it increases
dopamine that we've also big green is
used more in the brain when you increase
the app so so there's that and that
could increase your desire to learn and
your focus and other people say also
improve their ease of sociability that
they find it easy to talk to people and
others still say that it improves other
stimulants such as sunbeams like like
happy so did I experience these things
well to an extent guests in extent now
when I took three I got a bad headache
and I think that's because it's a
vasodilator I think the course code in
this meaning that it widens the blood
vessels made me a bit lightheaded I blow
but for anyways not ideal my try to I
had all of the brain fog which could
have been due to the potato Tom Curren
afternoon and when I tried just one it
was I didn't have any negative side
effects but the good side effects were
less so grab it bring back a bit tigers
from the from two taps but I did feel
some fix some benefits from that and I
the benefits were I do think that I had
more interest in learning I seems to
start work quicker with less fascination
that day I also found that I was more
absorbed in whilst learning I did more
research just out as I remembered a lot
more of it I also remembered a lot more
other small details especially in
conversation I was finding that I
remember things that people mentioned I
was focusing more on then less in my
head I'm often in my head I'm like one
of these daydreamer tight which I
actually like so I don't completely get
rid of that but on this I was better
able to concentrate a family people
saying more interesting so less of a
jackass so now regarded it did also
improve social even I didn't know I
didn't research that far before trying
it so in that regard it means it's
unlikely to have another seat back I
also think I was better at remembering
stuff that wasn't even recent that I
haven't learned whilst on this though of
remembering things from the past which I
would normally struggle to bring to mind
so that was interesting as well
especially cuz I can't think of what the
mechanism of action might be for that
yeah I didn't especially find that it
boosted the effect of stimulants
although did go very nicely with
modafinil
I don't recommend in the debt level as
I've said before but I thought I've
tried this combination just for the sake
of review and they didn't work quite all
together I also tried it with you have a
math tea because it's supposed to be
stupid with sound things and has three
sound things in it and I found that that
wasn't such a good comment
because by labor fresh like blood
specials again they've been issued
really dizzy which isn't great and like
all these things I don't think messing
with your brain chemistry on a regular
basis good idea don't get too worried
about messing with it because if you
think about it you're doing that every
time to take caffeine and it certainly
at the time we have alcohol and they
would be worried about that it's funny
how it's okay when you're doing it in a
way to ruin your brain you losing the
mind when you're actively trying to
improve it but still I think it's best
not to use keep nootropics things that
have an immediate effect onto regular
basis we're on to save them to keep them
effective and using just when you were
going to do a massive bit of research or
learning and that's probably how I would
use this as well as many people's gonna
give a speech or something because I
could say it does seems to improve my
presence and thus ease these sexual
experience but I wouldn't use it every
single day any new tricks I've been city
using every single day would just be
things to improve help like perhaps
omega-3 or something like that I would
also say the things that boost energy
may be such as creatine could be used
every day while you use create a Matt
Damon we've made the bodybuilding but
yeah something that gives you kind of
this acute focus it's messing with your
brain chemistry and I think using it
every single day is a little bit a
little bit short-sighted especially when
there's some uncertainty around
mechanisms of action I mean you wouldn't
even use alcohol every day and people
are starting to say that using caffeine
every day isn't such a good idea you can
see an article on that on the blog but
yes so my review is not a 5 out of 5
review but I would say that i would
prefer using this to modafinil I think
it's definitely safer than that there's
none of the kind of horrible negative
side effects using two capsules gave me
a little bit of brain fog a bit
tiredness something that people have
mentioned despite attempts to mitigate
that and using one as like a saying was
it was a mild experience say nothing
like modafinil
really but it did improve my desire to
learn I think a little bit and probably
this helped my memory so like I say
maybe I would use 1/2 of doing something
like a lot of research
in-depth article our topic I'm not new
with just occasionally and maybe I were
to consider using one before giving the
best man speech that I have to give next
week we'll see how that goes
oh it's in - it's actually not that
that's important to you at all or
specially different weapons in the
future but yeah so that's my review so
what's that
I'd say also fair mind everyone's going
to be different that's particular with
all new traits so just give it a go
III don't think this is one that you
have to avoid and the reviews on it
quite makes people like they've asked
really impressed love it and other
people say they have no effect at all do
your own brain chemistry and
expectations but for me it's been
interesting certainly something I might
occasionally turn to but it hasn't been
like a life-changing experience so
that's me out and I'll see you next time
for more videos in the future on here as
well as on my blog and we'll be looking
at more nandi terrific ways to boost
brainpower using things like meditation
brain training and lifestyle factors
which i think is a much better way to
enhance your grey matter and of course
I'll be uploading the usual videos on
health and fitness and training and some
other stuff like jumping higher and
punching harder so stay tuned if you
want to see that and thanks for watching
as always I'll see you next time